there are plenty of strong views about
the Muslim Brotherhood and its many
offshoots around the world several Arab
states have declared them a terrorist
organization
the Americans have yet to make up their
mind my guests here in amman jordan is
Dee Murtagh boob
she's an MP for the Islamic Action Front
the political wing of the Brotherhood
was King Abdullah right to accuse them
of being like wolves in sheep's clothing
[Music]
dear Metabo welcome to conflict zone
thank you Sam
a couple of years ago you gave an
interview in which you said you espoused
a moderate form of Islam you said our
belief is not that radical we believe in
moderate Islam but there's nothing
moderate about your views on violence is
there of course we totally condemn
violence right after the 14th of July
attacks in Jerusalem's holiest site for
Muslims and Jews to Israeli policemen
both Jews killed by three attackers and
your reaction was to glory in their
bloodshed wasn't it
well actually it's different from the
way we see it because we see the
Israelis as of aggressors the al-aqsa
mosque is a holy site for Muslims they
shouldn't be there in the first place so
there are the aggressors and the
Palestinian social Jews as well okay but
the Aqsa Mosque is a holy site where
Muslims pray so they are they shouldn't
they be there in the first place and
what the Palestinians are only there are
freedom fighters retaliating to the
Israeli address those are slogans though
aren't they you retweeted the following
you retweeted the three brave heroic men
who committed the act today on Friday
and then you said today only force and
the use of force can change the status
quo so your moderate credentials are
wearing a little thin aren't they no I
do believe we do see Israel as an enemy
we didn't change that and we do see the
Israelis as aggressors we do see the sin
as occupiers as surfers of our land and
he does as well he doesn't represent my
views but he represents the Palestinians
and this is a man who is trying he says
to stop the violence trying to unite
Hamas and Fatah so that he gets a
stronger negotiating position the way
you and you want to wreck that no the
way I view al-aqsa is that it's a
triumph or holy Muslims of a form of
holy find for Muslims not only for
Palestinians so all Muslims have a say
in the future of al-aqsa mosque and they
the majority believe that it has to be
freed from the Israeli occupation do
matter will be oh just you're just
perpetuating a cycle of
you know that this will end when it
doesn't at a negotiating table not in
bloodshed we're not we're not I don't
want to do the difficult thing which is
to make which is to unify the
Palestinians and make peace you just
want to kill who initiated the violence
the Palestinians did not initiate the
violence the Israelis initiated the
violence by occupying Palestine by
transgressing on holy site for Muslims
they initiated the violence you should
blame them for starting it the
Palestinians are only retaliating Israel
has to answer for what it does and says
and you are accountable for what you say
and do or do you have no sense of
personal responsibility no I I see them
as freedom fighters trying to free their
countries you have no sense of personal
responsibility I guess the worst thing
is that that you support violence
carried out by other groups but you
don't want to get your own hands dirty
do you this is the way you term it you
see it as violence I see it as a freedom
fighter but the majority of people who
want to free Palestine who still calls
for freeing Palestine see it as
retaliation as they know they see them
as freedom fighters if you think the
attacks are so what you see as violence
is only defending our country if you
think the attacks were so brilliant why
don't why don't you take part or are you
just going to go on applauding from the
sidelines no I'm not a freedom fighter
I'm only a politician my role as a
politician is to support people who are
trying to free their country or the
motor of violence in this instance this
is the way you see so King Abdullah was
right when he said four years ago that
the Muslim Brotherhood and groups like
you weak and you're the political wing
of the Muslim Brotherhood
you were like wolves in sheep's clothing
he's right no the man in one hand you
say a parliament and then you promote
violence not this is this is your term
you are using violence as I said I see
it as you know trying to free our
country trying to free the most holy
sites of Muslims which is al-aqsa mosque
yesterday the Jordanian Parliament
has supported what has happened in
al-aqsa mosque you see can you see
that's all the part are dodging in
Parliament is also supporting violence
violence as you know doesn't get you one
step nearer a resolution does it no
Israelis did not get any stepford that
the settlements are still theirs they're
still expanding no rights no human
rights whatever for the Palestinians so
it didn't get any it didn't get us
anywhere also to negotiate with the
Israelis demons have you've left far
behind the declared peaceful ideals of
the Muslim Brotherhood haven't you
in 2015 the london-based deputy supreme
guide of the Muslim Brotherhood
Ibrahim muniya was quite clear about
rejecting violence he said there wasn't
mother has committed to peaceful means
civic and societal struggle political
engagement violence is condemned and
rejected in whatever form or method it
occurs whoever the perpetrators and
whatever the motives you seem to have
very different ideas or maybe these
principles of yours just come and go
okay to put it straight in the first
place I'm not spokesman of the
spokesperson of the Muslim Brotherhood
not all members of the IAF are mem and
members of the Muslim Brotherhood okay I
understand that but I'm saying you've
left far behind these peaceful no we do
believe we do believe that if we are in
a country a civil country which not
suffering from occupation and resisting
occupation is a human rights which is
acknowledged by all forms of
international law if we live in a civic
society we go by the rules of that
society okay we do not initiate violence
but if we live in an occupied country
you know you said a moment ago that
you're keen on human rights but your
friends in Hamas don't do human rights
do this doesn't that bother you do these
really human rights is that an answer do
two wrongs make a right not at all
you condemn the Israelis for what they
do you do the same thing they started
the cycle of violent or better they
started the cycle of violence you do not
expect the Palestinian to just take that
violence and be silent about it and what
they do to their own people you are
silent about in its annual report this
year Human Rights Watch accused the
Palestinian authorities in Gaza and the
West Bank of restricting freedom of
expression and torturing and
ill-treating detainees of their own
Palestinian human rights groups said the
same thing why don't you speak up about
that if you care about human rights
nothing to do is reformed of that report
but I do say if you know Hamas is did
that it's strong okay and it should you
know do something right about it but
that you cannot sway this thing with the
Israeli aggression
you cannot take only that point and if
Hamas has done it okay it should do
things to clear that up not you cannot
say every government there's a lot of
wrong things to its people the same
thing but you cannot weigh that at the
same time with Israeli violence Israeli
violence have to be you know retaliated
against and they're only doing their
human rights Metta boob the same report
also condemns Hamas as rocket strikes
and points out that a UN Commission of
Inquiry last year found that such
attacks were serious violations of the
laws of war because they were
indiscriminate attacks on Israeli
population centers are you happy to be
associated with serious violations of
the laws of war as I said I'm not to
speak for Hamas or the Muslim brothers
pretty close to them using using white
phosphorus by the Israelis also is not
related for what you and your friends
promote I said as I told you ask me
about well Jordan asked me about the
Muslim brother about Jordan my the pinch
line is that I support the right of any
human group whether it be in Palestine
or elsewhere to retaliate against
aggression and occupation let's look at
another issue that you do care about
which is homosexuality
you were very forthright about that you
fought hard to get a a concert cancelled
here because of the sexuality of the
lead singer in a Lebanese band a man
called Hamid sin oh you actually told a
TV interview it's exactly because of his
sexuality that you wanted the concert
cancelled and you said it was because of
concerns by citizens what message did
you want to get out the Tama sections
aren't welcome in Jordan yes this is the
this is not only my message I have
people to welcome yeah I I have people
to represent the people who are
represented they informed me and they
asked me to come okay I'm not the only
one a lot of my colleagues have also
participated in the same effort to you
know to prevent this group from coming
so it was a kind of a unanimous decision
between the members and okay no because
the Ministry of Interior has you know I
cancelled the party so the thing is that
I'm not the only one who said that it
was a group let's say of of MPs who have
called all ministers of the government
to take their role in cancelling this
party and not allowing the group to come
to Jordan are you happy that as a result
of this mr. Sinnoh has been swamped with
threats of violence and death threats
are you pleased about that this is not
my responsibility because you he was
marked out stigmatize my feel
discriminated against my responsibility
is towards the door damien people what
the Jordanian people see is fit and
representing their ideals and morals I
have to represent them and mr. Chenault
has no right and I didn't I didn't take
any of his rights
I just prevent obscure all the
atmosphere in which you don't have any
rights in your eyes he's not gay
I'd like to use I'd like to call a spade
a spade and we call him a homosexual
he's not a gay to us and I said my first
and foremost responsibility is towards
the Jordanian people what the Jordanian
people see as fit and welcoming we
welcome them welcome welcome them and
that's my only
you're a dangerous wrote here because
promoting intolerance and marking people
out as sinners leads to extremists in
this country proving that they're ready
to kill even for an accusation look at
now head hata the Christian writer who
last year faced charges of insulting
Islam and was gunned down outside a
court here in Jordan
he hadn't been convicted of anything but
the accusations were enough to get him
killed you don't mind that no no of
course I've issued a statement at the
time Carter was killed or assassinated
and we said that this was a crime what
has happened is totally unjustified the
thing has should it should take it its
course in the legal courts but this was
as a Member of Parliament I'm supposed
to voice what the Jordanian people want
so what happened in that band is that I
waste the you know the the voice of the
Jordanian people and I took it as a
responsibility too you won't tell me how
many but do you claim to speak for the
whole Jordanian people but I don't claim
to speak to the Jordanian people I claim
to speak to a lot who have called and
you know Aspen and there were a lot who
wanted more than 300 they were more than
300 so take also my colleagues and the
people who asked them you would see some
people well you know we're totally and
it's all it took it took a great let's
say a great fuss on the you know on the
media on facebook on Twitter on all
forms of communication and there was an
extreme rejection and the people who
really worked on them
was just minority why don't you stop
promoting intolerance before someone
else gets killed this is nothing for
someone else gets killed we we you seem
to be blaming now had hot air for
secularism you tweeted that secularism
was driving the country towards an abyss
so you were almost blaming him there
what happened do you not do not
interpret what I didn't say okay I said
that in transportation in secularism in
a country which Constitution says that
it's an Islamic country the the religion
of Jordan is Islam this is what is said
in a constitute in our constitution and
if you want to say that Jordan is a
country
of law and institutions then if the law
says that this is not allowed the law
should take its course what happened to
no headhunter is unacceptable
unjustified the law should have taken
his core its course in his case this is
what I am only promoting what the
ministry did in the case of that band is
that it's used its power its
jurisdiction to prevent that band from
coming to Jordan this is still lawful de
matamoros earlier this year you
celebrated the release of a murderer
here in Jordan called Ahmed da Kamsa not
just any murderer but a former Jordanian
soldier who in 1997 opened fire on a
group of young Israeli schoolgirls
because he said they had mocked him
while he was praying there was no
evidence of that and you not only think
that murdering children is okay you make
this man into a hero a man found by a
military tribunal convicted him of being
mentally unstable and you make a hero
out of him for killing 13 and 14 year
old Israeli schoolgirls as your hatred
of Israel taking away your last vestiges
of humanity well you may not only blame
me for that you may also blame a lot of
the Jordanian people Jordanian people
now as he said this is a Jordanian day
of celebration exactly I still listen we
considered him to be free because no one
can arrest someone like the soldier that
can say we congratulate the people who
continue up to uphold the prison this is
my viewpoint asking you about you you
why did why do you have so little
humanity on the death of seven
unprotected Israelis this is your parts
of the story Tim you're accusing me of
it it's the chance there are always two
sides of the coin you're looking to your
sides of the coin and accusing upon that
I don't know how it looks good a man
opening fire fourteen-year-old girls
okay they're not only school girls they
were people who mocked our country who
mocked our release you only have his
words right
you only have
it was no because he was mentally
unstable as your word he was found
mentally unstable unstable to us he's
not mentally unstable so you're not able
to make proper judgment a lot of the
people still see him as a hero so if
you're incriminating my fave you point
you're also incriminating their voice
viewpoint of the Johnny heroes you have
people who kill schoolgirls you think
it's brave - I was considered a hero by
the Israelis who committed the massacre
as I said to you we asked the Israelis
about what they do I'm asking you about
what you do and what you think you think
it's brave to shoot at kids who have no
protection
that's bravery to you it's part of your
story we enjoyed a lot of the Jordanian
people actually still view admitted the
cancer as a hero because he retaliated
to the mockery of Israelis he didn't
retaliate he shot unarmed school girls
the late King Hussein pologize went
personally to apologise to the Israeli
families of the victims he sat in all
humility with them and shared their pain
but you didn't feel any pain at all I'm
aware of that I'm aware of that and I'm
still aware of the pain of a lot of
Palestinians who were also massacred in
the Hebron mosque your praise for that
cancers actions actually encourages
others to do the same doesn't it by
legitimizing these killings you helped
legitimize the murder of children
everywhere don't you not at all
because I said you have to put the thing
in context the context says that this we
are in we have an enemy the enemy is
Israel if we are put in a in an enemy
state with them then it's our role to
reach out come on where'd you draw the
line
baby starts 3 year olds 3 year olds
where do you draw the line you've got to
stop some I draw the line I draw the
line you're a mother I'm a mother and
you're quite happy to have 13 and 14
year old just because they're Israelis
killed
13 or 14 year olds and that's enough a
lot of 14 year old Palestinians were
killed and massacred why don't you
defend them also you know many people
around the world will judge views like
yours to be obscene and inhuman do you
care you're someone who recommends and
praises the killing of children is that
what you want to be known for you and
your movement you want to be known for
that not at all Tim you have to consider
contextualize everything that you see
okay and dust just don't repeat still
hard to find a nice context all the
Islamic movements under the same shed
you're asking me about a settled country
which was Jordan which I present as an
MP here we're a civil society we call
for the respect of human rights in
Palestine it's totally a different issue
except unless you're a 13 or 14 year old
school Palestinians who were massacred
everything makes this okay does it when
you're responding to a say killing your
children target kill vetch when you
respond there when you're responding to
a person who started the cycle of
violence okay who started killing you
who started massacring you yeah what
makes your position even more remarkable
is that you you sit in Parliament here
in Amman in Jordan discussing so-called
protections for women and girls and then
go and Cheer the murder of 13 and 14
year old girls that's some hypocrisy is
not at all because I as I told you you
have to contextualize in Jordan where
reciving society with a society of law
and order with a society that protects
human rights in a palace in Palestine
it's a totally different issue it's a
totally different story
why don't you see the killing and
murdering and massacring of Palestinian
women of Palestinian children every day
people who go to pray are being killed
and massacred people who are just trying
to perform their worship I mean once
want some context Demeter who in 2006
members of the Islamic Action Front went
to offer condolences here on the death
of the al Qaeda
senior commander in our
Abu Musab al-zarqawi and this was just a
year after al-qaeda had blown up three
hotels in a man and killed 60 innocent
people and your Islamic Action Front was
offering condolences to the former head
of the group who carried out this
atrocity in your own capital yeah I I
don't condone that I don't see that as
fit I think it's just still I don't
defend if there's something wrong with
those how to defend it all the way I see
that as an individual you know opinion
they acted on their own you know whim
let's say I don't defend that at all
because our position towards terrorist
organization is very clear at the party
we see that as a terrorist organization
we did not you know support their own
choice of going and you know offering
condolences and after that our position
towards any terrorist group is very
clear and very clear correctly okay but
you also you say that but you also seen
you and the Muslim Brotherhood are seen
as part of a conveyor belt that feeds at
least some of your members into the arms
of militant organizations the Center on
religion and geopolitics said two years
ago that a quarter of prominent jihadis
from the Middle East in Africa had links
to the Muslim Brotherhood before they
joined militant groups not at all
because your party beta's accusing you
you incubate not amazing using this
source that you have cited I will also
cite the UK report which was issued in
Tuesday 2016 by the special foreign
Committee which said that the Muslim
Brotherhood is a firewall against
extremism so you have your sources I
have my sources also which say that you
know and it doesn't worry you that
figures like Ayman al-zawahiri now
leader of al-qaeda and Abdullah Azzam
known by some as the father of global
jihad also showed that same path as you
through the Muslim doesn't worry you at
all no it's not the coincidence every
person can you know believe in an
ideology at a certain time and go astray
and change their minds so you have to
see the performance the total the total
fallacy of the performance of the Muslim
Brotherhood in their different countries
what is it that so many of those who go
on to become terrorists passed through
their hands it's not our problem a lot
of people you know move move between
different ideologies and they you know
do all kinds of actions but the way you
can assess the performance it's pure
coincidence its sheer coincidence makes
people to believe that and I'm not
responsible for what people believe but
see the performance of the Muslim
Brotherhood and other Islamic movements
who did not go to the path of extremism
you will see that they you have
preserved the security and stability of
their countries look at the Muslim
Brotherhood in Jordan in the period of
the Arab Spring the Muslim Brotherhood
has been very wise enough to tailor its
own kind of reform in other countries
said you're divided and weakened not at
all no they said with your own not at
all I think that now as a party were
strong the Muslim I'm not responsible as
I told you to respond to its response
for the Muslim Brotherhood but I'm just
assessing the situation as a politician
coming back to my point they tried they
tailored art spring in in in Jordan to
say we want to reform not overthrew the
regime or the government so this was you
know creating a kind of let's say
preserving the stability of the
Jordanian people trying to reform within
the limits that we have and we have also
come into Parliament because we see
ourselves as part and parcel of society
that we go with the limits of society we
do not go and clash with society alright
we've already discussed some of your
limits and red lines Dimity boob thanks
very much for being on completely
welcome thank you welcome
[Music]
you